[Música]
sin que todavía haya un resultado
oficial de las elecciones
estadounidenses donald trump ya denunció
fraude amenazó con recurrir al tribunal
supremo para detener el reconteo total
de votos y reclamó su victoria por su
parte joe biden afirmó que está en el
camino de la victoria y advirtió al
mandatario que la elección corresponde a
los votantes
todavía cualquiera de los dos candidatos
puede ganar la contienda está por ahora
con 238 votos electorales para bailén y
213 para trump y restan siete estados
con por escrutar los candidatos
necesitan 270 votos electorales como
mínimo para llegar a la casa blanca
enlazamos ahí
este año los latinos volvieron a dar su
apoyo a donald trump quien aventajó en
más de tres puntos porcentuales a su
rival demócrata joe biden en florida
texas también le dio su apoyo a los
republicanos entre ambos estados aportan
67 votos electorales al presidente y
california y no méxico votaron demócrata
y le aportaron 60 votos a joe biden
[Música]
buenos días soy alan austria bienvenidos
a este avance de noticias un día después
de las elecciones presidenciales de eeuu
es que todavía nada está definido y el
escenario es el de un recuento muy
ajustado el panorama político y social
estadounidense pinta complicado luego de
que el candidato presidente de donald
trump denunció esta madrugada fraude
electoral sin aportar pruebas ni
fundamentos y amenazó con recurrir al
tribunal supremo para detener el
reconteo total de los votos cuando ni
siquiera se ha terminado el conteo
oficial esto es un fraude para el pueblo
estadounidense es una desgracia para el
país estábamos listos para ganar esta
elección francamente ganamos esta
elección
[Aplausos]
entonces nuestro objetivo ahora es
asegurar la integridad por el bien de
esta nación es un gran momento este es
una un gran fraude fraude mayor para
esta nación y queremos que se utilice la
ley de manera apropiada entonces iremos
a la corte suprema además el mandatario
afirmó que según sus cálculos la
votación iba por buen camino en muchos
estados
también aseguró que predijo lo que iba a
ocurrir la noche del 3 de noviembre
refiriéndose una vez más sin fundamentos
al fraude por voto por correo dijo que
llevarán el proceso electoral al
tribunal supremo para que este organismo
sea quien valide todo el proceso de
votación
tuvimos una gran gran noche simplemente
veamos todos estos estados que hemos
ganado esta noche y miramos el tipo de
márgenes que tenemos y de repente no es
como que hayamos ganado por 12 votos
y de repente dije que le pasa a la
elección
y tenemos todas estas personas y
anunciantes diciendo buenos porque saben
que no podían ganar entonces dijeron
vamos a la corte
tienen que yo van a mandar decenas de
miles de votos por el lado demócrata el
candidato joe biden dijo que su campaña
se siente muy bien con respecto a dónde
están y cree que van por muy buen camino
para ganar la elección
[Aplausos]
nos sentimos bien con respecto a dónde
estamos realmente así es estoy aquí para
decirles esta noche que creemos que
vamos en camino a ganar esta elección
sabemos por los votos anticipados sin
precedentes y los votos por correo que
esto va a tomar tiempo tendremos que ser
pacientes hasta que la ardua tarea de
contar los votos haya terminado y esto
no se acaba hasta que cada voto haya
sido contado hasta el último voto
[Aplausos]
miren podríamos conocer los resultados
tan pronto como mañana en la mañana pero
puede que tarde un poco más como he
dicho todo el tiempo no me corresponde
ni a mí ni a donald trump declarar quién
ganó de estas elecciones esa es la
decisión del pueblo estadounidense pero
soy optimista sobre este resultado en
qué parte saca
desde las inmediaciones de la casa
blanca en washington está nuestro
corresponsal cristóbal vázquez buenos
días en la capital estadounidense a
cristóbal como amanece hoy washington y
la casa blanca cuál es el balance de lo
ocurrido ayer
a mares en una tensa calma la casa
blanca los medios de comunicación y los
estadounidenses no saben si las palabras
de el presidente trump fueron una
amenaza de las que hace el presidente
constantemente o si es efectivamente un
llamado acción para que la corte
suprema- empiece a investigar cualquier
tipo de fraude sin antes haber acabado
el conteo también hay reacciones incluso
de los republicanos del presentador
chris wallace que es uno de los
presentadores estrellas de la cadena fox
news que es de corte conservador y
republicano y ha dicho que la situación
ya estaba en una inflamable que fue el
presidente con el que le prendió llamas
también chris christie ex gobernador del
estado de nueva jersey ha reaccionado
diciendo que las palabras del presidente
franz son una estrategia mal jugada que
son lamentables y también los
periodistas de la talla también de raudo
no decidí es que ha dicho que
simplemente las palabras
y los sellos cristóbal vázquez muchas
gracias por tu reporte nuestro
corresponsal en washington por supuesto
seguiremos contigo del desarrollo de
estas elecciones presidenciales desde la
casa blanca y es que eeuu presentó su
mayor participación desde 1900 revisemos
los resultados que hasta el momento se
tienen del conteo de votos electorales a
lo largo y ancho del país con 238 votos
electorales
joe biden obtiene los votos de los
estados de washington oregón colorado
nuevo méxico minnesota illinois nuevo
hampshire nueva york virginia vermont
rhode island connecticut nueva jersey
delaware el distrito de columbia
maryland y tiene un estrecho margen de
victoria en el importante estado de
arizona entretanto donald trump ganó en
montana idaho dakota del norte y dakota
del sur nebraska kansas yuta oklahoma
texas iowa misurí arkansas indiana ohio
virginia occidental kentucky
y mississippi alabama carolina del sur
luisiana y el importante estado de
florida los estados que quedan por
definir son 7 alaska nevada wisconsin
michigan pensilvania carolina del norte
y georgia de acuerdo con las
proyecciones de la agencia ap el estado
de nevada le quedaría a biden y el
estado de alaska a donald trump de
manera que la presidencia de eeuu
quedaría en manos de cinco estados que
de acuerdo con expertos electorales by
the necesitaría dos de estos cinco
estados mientras que trump necesitaría
cuatro estos resultados pueden llegar
incluso a tomarse varios días en ser
contados
y se esperaba que el voto latina fuera
clave para definir estas elecciones así
quedó demostrado con las intenciones de
los candidatos que intensificaron sus
campañas en los últimos días en un
estado como florida el propio donald
trump hizo un twitter en español publicó
en español también concedió entrevistas
a medios mexicanos justo la jornada
antes de la votación este año los
latinos volvieron a dar apoyo a trump
quien aventajó en más de tres puntos
porcentuales a su rival demócrata joe
biden en florida y es que trump ganó
también en texas otro estado con gran
presencia de la comunidad hispana pero
porque los latinos votan por trump como
vamos a escuchar para algunos trump
representa el éxito estadounidense y
para otros especialmente venezolanos y
cubanos
el republicano es el candidato que se
enfrenta al socialismo
estoy aquí para apoyar a nuestro
presidente creo que ha hecho un buen
trabajo a pesar de la pandemia a pesar
de todo ha hecho un trabajo increíble
está recuperando la economía recuperó
empleos arregló nuestros acuerdos
comerciales se preocupa por el pueblo
estadounidense cuando ningún otro
político lo ha hecho es porque donald
trump no es un político
viniendo de cuba- todos sabemos cómo
hacer comunismo y el socialismo y
obviamente la era de fidel castro- weiss
francos entre comillas nuestro
presidente nuestro dictador como quieras
llamarlo en nuestro país todavía está en
el comunismo
honestamente eso no va a cambiar puede
que pase mucho tiempo pero sabemos cómo
se ve uy no conocemos las promesas
falsas cuando alguien las dice y joe
biden básicamente los está dando
promesas falsas
gracias seguimos en francés 24
[Música]